but first we're going to start with this
there's been a dramatic shift in the
laws on abortion affecting millions of
women in this country in North Carolina
abortion rights supporters protested
last night's vote by Republican
lawmakers to override the governor's
veto and established a 12-week limit on
abortions in Montana where the state
constitution protects abortion rights
the governor signed a bill yesterday
there to Outlaw the most common method
of abortion after 15 weeks Montana and
North Carolina joined other
republican-controlled states in reducing
abortion access Caitlyn Huey Burns is in
Raleigh that of course is the capital of
North Carolina with more on the story
Caitlin good morning to you
good morning Gail well North Carolina
had been one of the few remaining states
in the South with access to abortion now
it joins 19 other states that have
either banned or restricted the
procedure and to get it done Republicans
here push the measure through in just 42
hours
the bill becomes law at North Carolina
state capitol in Raleigh Tuesday night
Republicans overruled the Democratic
governor
foreign
restrictions under the new law which
goes into effect July 1st most abortions
will be banned after 12 weeks of
pregnancy a reduction from 20 weeks
under the previous law The veto stamp
has been applied just three days earlier
North Carolina's Democratic governor Roy
Cooper rejected the bill it will make
abortion unavailable to many women but
his power is limited last month a
democratic state representative from the
liberal-leaning Charlotte area switched
parties just five months after elections
I will not be controlled by anyone the
change gave Republicans a super majority
and the power to override vetoes from
Governor Cooper is there anything that
you can do unilaterally on the issue of
abortion we will never stop fighting to
protect Women's Health the White House
protested late Tuesday night saying
women have been left with no choice but
to travel hundreds of miles for the care
they need we just helped a patient from
Alabama we went to a clinic in Raleigh
last October that was already seeing a
surge in out-of-state patients they
drove a 10 and a half hour trip to make
sure they were at the clinic at nine
o'clock that morning 10 and a half hours
each way
now there are only two states in the
South that offer unrestricted relatively
unrestricted access to abortion that's
Virginia and neighboring South Carolina
but Gail Republicans in South Carolina
are working to push through a six-week
abortion ban
all right Caitlin the conversation
continues thank you very much